Lost River is the directorial debut of
Ryan Gosling it's also written by Ryan
Gosling and it stars Christina Hendricks
as well as Ben Mendelsohn jira Ronan and
Matt Smith now if I were to describe
this movie I would say it's a fantasy
even though looking at this movie would
think it's fantasy it's kind of a fairy
tale like fantasy and I gotta say it's
probably the weirdest movie I've seen so
far in 2015 now this is coming from the
guy who really enjoyed under the skin as
well as enemy and only God forgives for
me to be saying this movie is the
weirdest film I saw this year that syncs
the movie takes place in a sort of
fictionalized version of Detroit in
which this neighborhood in town is
decaying houses are catching on fire
being burnt to the ground there's this
crazy guy played by Matt Smith or Doctor
Who for some of you who've Ian fans out
there he's wandering around and causing
chaos Christina Hendricks plays a mother
trying to raise her children without any
money and her home is being threatened
to be knocked down and ben mendelsohn
offers her a job at this strange
nightclub that seems to use violence as
a fetish of some kind
this is a weird movie while her son is
investigating this mystery of a dinosaur
a theme park that was flooded and turned
into a reservoir I told you is a weird
one guys now I was really looking
forward to this movie because yes I am a
fan of Ryan Gosling as an actor I like a
lot of the projects that he chooses but
I'm also a fan of art I love art and I
like what a filmmaker can show something
maybe doesn't necessarily make sense
maybe it's not very cohesive
maybe the narrative structure is flawed
and broken but the images that are there
are thought-provoking Lost River has a
lot of that there are a lot of moments
throughout Lost River that I was truly
affected by in a visual sense there's
also a lot of elements of this film that
you can really tell Gosling is pulling
from people he's worked with before
there's definitely Nicolas Winding
roughen in here there's Derek C on
France in here in regards to people that
I don't think he's worked with before
David Lynch and his surrealistic
dreamlike imagery is very prevalent in
this movie so some might say like that's
a bit like he's copying off of other
filmmakers and some of those complaints
are a little bit warranted because there
are a lot of aspects of this movie that
don't feel like it's one filmmaker it
does feel like he's
from all kinds of people that he's
worked with before you can easily look
at a film like this and say this is
truly horrible this is one of the worst
movies I've ever seen I can also see
people saying it's a masterpiece because
at the Cannes Film Festival it was booed
and then cheered and then boot again and
then all this craziness everything was
divided you know what I mean it takes a
lot of balls to make a movie this
audacious this different this original
that being said there are large
stretches of this film that don't work
it's almost like rotten castling was
upset that people are saying the only
God forgives torture scene was too
violent so we decided to have a scene in
which an animal is tortured which I
didn't want to see and I thought was
really unnecessary and completely out of
left field and just unwarranted in every
way and I hated it in all honesty I
couldn't stand that moment and I really
did not need to see that there's also a
lot of moments in this film that just do
not make sense and you're starting to
wonder if it even makes sense for
Gosling or if he just wanted to try to
create startling imagery or do something
that was different
I give him major props for the fact that
this is his first big movie and he did
something very different and he didn't
do the conventional safe thing you know
he did a very odd and off-kilter movie
and if you're watching very closely
during one of the club scenes someone is
wearing a skull mask it is right out of
Batman Returns my best way to describe
this movie is you take a really great
artist likes a Picasso he has a paint
bucket and he fills it with all of his
favorite colors he takes that paint
bucket and he throws it on a canvas it
explodes everywhere you have a great
artist Ryan Gosling he has a lot of
great ideas he throws them all into this
movie they just don't mesh it's
entertaining at times for its
originality but as a whole it just
doesn't work and there are a lot of
moments in regards to character arcs and
things just making sense that just don't
I'm going to give Lost River a scene I
admire Gosling for having the audacity
to make such a different movie and to
put some things in there that are just
blatantly offensive like violence
against animals for no particular reason
but the same time really good
cinematography and a great score can't
really save the fact this movie doesn't
have much of a script at all and it's
largely style over substance so guys if
you have seen Lost River I'm interested
in knowing what you thought below thank
you so much for watching also if you
want to check out my review for Mission
Impossible it's my first in my series of
every Mission Impossible movie as well
as some other Tom Cruise movies thrown
throughout leading to Mission Impossible
rogue nation it's on my channel right
now guys thank you so much as always and
if you liked this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes